you know that alex actually was more
than just a host he was a pop culture
icon even hollywood was starstruck
and if imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery
well will ferrell may have everybody
beat
welcome to celebrity jeopardy rock and
roll edition
from snl and the golden girls to sesame
street and cheers
alex was game to make fun of his own
image marnie
flip that coin
the fawns may have been the coolest guy
around but a lot of sand has fallen
through the hourglass since he last
appeared on television
where is alex drop your weapon you too
[Applause]
lady
that's right but on weekends i'm park
ranger
alex trebek and i'm here to save you
i read your smoke signals telling me
that there were women here in
jeopardy we're part of the american
cultural scene
and it's kind of neat to have people
poke fun at us and i like it would you
like to make more money
impress your friends be like me and know
everything in the world
sure you would you're feeling very
sleepy
very relaxed once for april fool's day
alex actually hosted wheel of fortune
welcome to our special tuesday
april 1st edition of wheel of fortune
i'll leave you to figure out
why i'm here today decade after decade
alex not only loved being both a host
and a teacher
he also got a kick out of making us
laugh i
guess i'll be gone forever oh no no no
steven
we'll always be there for the american
people whenever they need us the most
right yeah but aren't you canadian
from all of us to all of you good night
good night
by the way alex eventually did become an
american citizen yeah we were glad
he did
[Music]
so many people have said that alex
trebek made it cool to be smart well he
did
because he was smart you know he had a
degree in philosophy from the university
of ottawa so
we're going to leave you with more of
alex's wise words
alex trebek gone but never forgot no
good night everybody
i want the viewers to like me and
over the years they have demonstrated
that they do and i'm very proud of that
game shows are feel good television you
know it's the american dream
i can be a success i can be a winner the
advice i give to young people all the
time is pay your dues
and after you put in the time then
you'll feel not only more confident when
you get
the big job but you'll feel
hey i earned it it didn't just happen by
accident
[Music]
you